here's alonzo went four for 11 in the
series in pittsburgh nemo at first and
nobody out
and pete sucks one to deep left and
forget that that is way out of here and
alonso goes deep and the mets have an
instant two-nothing lead making home run
number 15 on the road for alonso 18th of
the year but pete has hit most of his
long balls on the road and in a good
hitter's park he's got all smiles as he
had it's back to the mets dugout jeff's
got an eight-game hitting streak going
up to 257 for the year still trying to
get into some kind of a groove
curveball drilled out to right center
field back in the gap toward the wall
it's out of here
alonso and mcneil go back to back
great american band box and it's three
nothing new york
good line
fourth home run of the year for mcneil
and the mets having a party in the first
inning and he got all of that one jeff's
swinging a hot bat right now i'm
beginning to show some power too
tenth straight game that mcneal has
reached base safely we told you that
gutierrez normally gets into trouble
with his fastball he had only given up
one home run all season on a breaking
pitch until just now and he's giving up
back-to-back homers now winker on india
at third base tyler stevenson
stands in rookie has had a great year
stevenson double play ball to short
bubbled and lost by guillaume a safe
slide a second by winker india scores
stevenson safe at first 3-1 the normally
short-handed guillermo
hooting one that should have been easy
double play
bases loaded huge chance for tyler
naquin
naquin loops this one over third
splashes down fair
winker scores stevenson scores to tie it
bottom to third a two-run double from
tyler naked even at three
john sometimes it's not about how hard
you hit it this ball certainly was not
one of the typical blast from naquin one
down shogo akiyama
in the air to left field dominic smith
back makes the catch against the wall
bottle breaks from third nate went up to
third sac fly rbi and the reds lead four
to three
that could have been a whole lot worse
but dom smith making a nice play right
before he got to the wall to catch that
long sacrifice fly from akiyama
and he strikes him out with the curve
ball and that retires the side but not
before the reds posed a four-run bottom
of the first to take a one-run lead
[Applause]
ground ball should be two mcneal throws
it away and everybody's safe
two innings two double play chances two
errors on the mets infield
and this is not what jared eichhoff
needed he's a contact pitcher and the
mets are letting him down
nikov's got another mess on his hands as
tyler stevenson steps in he rounds this
one to shore he's going to go to third
but he dropped it another error and then
he knocks it out of play and that's
going to bring in a run
it's a comedy of errors
luis guiorme in there for his
shorthandedness and he makes a second
error and they could even charge him
with two errors on that play
bottom that's gonna get down left center
field winker walks home stevenson
sputters through second sprints for
third get down slides it safely
six three cincinnati
lakewood had a bloop two run double his
first time
dribbler stevenson breaks from third
bare hand no play
stevenson scores infield hit for tyler
and aquin what a barrage by the reds 7-3
those mets have their fifth hit against
gutierrez now here's conforto let's get
in the air fairly deep to right field
naquin looking up and that ball is gone
they get five home runs for michael
conforto but we've got a seven to five
ball game now and we're only in the
fourth
so two fastballs two home runs two days
for conforto two in scoring position for
alonso
and he reaches for it and flicks it out
to right that's gonna fall for a base in
in his neato they'll stop ikoff at third
but alonso gets the mets a little bit
closer with that rbi single now 7-6
cincinnati one bowl one strike gun
dominic smith pitch
that's lifted in the air that's deep
toward right center field back forward
at the wall is akiyama and it's gone
it's long gone about halfway up the
bleachers in right center field dominic
smith crushes a game-tying homer and the
mets are back to even it is 7-7 in the
fifth inning a dumb bomb his tenth of
the year two one and two on the tie game
in the fifth
and winker pops one up
jd davis should have a play
and that retires the side big out for
yency diaz as he gets the foul out from
winker to keep it tied after five
miguel castro on the pitch for the mets
at the bottom of the sixth and tyler
stevenson it's a hot shot in alonzo with
a nice play and gets him at first
beautifully done by pete alonso with the
sit spin and that's the first down in
the sixth well this ball hit in such a
way that it was kind of a in between
high hop for pete and he stayed with it
and makes the nice transfer to castro
making it more difficult on himself now
has to face jesse winker with two men on
winker hammers it to right field
and winker unties it barnhart flies
around third stop sign for india a
go-ahead ripping double by jesse winker
8-7
now james mccann is going to bat for
tomas nido looking maybe for a little
more power here a chance for mccann to
hit a two-run shot or
and mccann gets under one deep left
field back goes winker to the warning
track back at the wall it's out of here
james mccann with a two-run pitch hit
home run and the mets go in front nine
to eight
send up the power bat and it comes
through
like a good poker player dave joss got
to know one to hold him or when to fold
him
trying to hang on he's never had three
consecutive blown saves
winker in the left center
he's gonna tie the game aquino flies
home and scores winker head first plunge
the throw lost
and winker in scoring position
tied
up pinch hitter in the eighth of a
two-run homer and mccann gets jammed it
goes past the pitcher into center field
a base hit that'll bring in pillar with
the go-ahead run james mccann comes
through again his third rbi off the
bench tonight and the mets go in front
10 to nine in the 10th
first and third nobody out down a run
little punk to left tai gay
freeman scores 10 10. o2 coming slashed
on the ground down to third handled by
peraza side retired and we're going to
the 11th round the go ahead run at third
nimmo at first
mcneal to line drive to right center a
base hit peraza scores nimo is on his
way to third he'll make it there
standing up jeff mcneil an rbi single
and the vents are back in front
pilar hits one of the air to deep left
field back goes aquino near the wall
it's out of here
kevin
deep right center forget that that is
way out of here back to back home runs
for the mets for the second time
tonight pillar and conforto back to back
and it's 15 to 10. freeman reaches
joseph daniel votto come to the plate as
a potential tying run 3-2 coming from me
to freeman
he struck him out and the ball game is
over the mitts win a back and forth
marathon
they hit seven home runs and it's just
enough and the mets win a wild one in
cincinnati in 11 innings 15. to 11.